and yeah I decided to go and be with
other women beginning with like 50 women
is she a three or four for example 100
yeah so women counts as body the same
way oh 100 okay so if she was with 10
men and 10 women
I want to do it would you rather okay
would you rather date a girl she's I've
already been there she's got she's got
10 bodies from guys five from girls or
would you rather have vice versa 10
bodies from girls five from guys because
of my past experience I'd prefer her to
have bodies from guys
what can you say what went wrong because
of my past experience like I was like
when I was young like I was in my 20s my
second like major relationship
I was in a relationship with a woman who
was bisexual right and at that age I was
like 20 that was early twenty I was like
oh but I said that's great yeah great no
well exactly for you yeah threesome why
they just because it's like if you fall
in love with somebody who's a who's a
bisexual and they come to you one day
and say ah women you're like uh I can't
compete with that as a man because men
as in the competition because as a man
I'm I'm competitive by Nature because I
want to be able to quote unquote please
my woman
and I'm like hang on so what I'm doing
is not pleasing you I'm gonna say nobody
knows a woman like a woman like I was
like oh snap like yeah I'm not enough
you need to leave then like my thing was
that okay you need to go because if I'm
not enough for you clearly then you just
not where you need to be so as a man
who's experienced it I was like nah I'm
not down for that women that like women
stuff that's just me it'd be too much
you pick it'd be too much headache
because I wouldn't know who I'm
competing with so yeah so like she could
be like Oh I'm going on a girl's night
[Applause]
it's a slippery slope it is a really
slippery slope when I get from a man's
perspective why they'd be like because
people that aren't like a bit naive to
it and just think oh it's just silly
there's a there's a lot of things that
can happen between two women and yeah so
it is a lot to do like if you're going
out of your girls and then you don't
come back and like if my girl I know
she's 100 straight like then I know for
a fact that she's just gone back to her
friend's house right they've they're
gonna have something I'm going to sleep
you know what I mean but like if I know
that you like women as well then like
you could be getting freaky with your
friend that's it bro and the thing is
you can't compete with that you can't
it's like when like you just don't know
there's a I think there's a um there's a
there's an ego in men also you know what
I mean like if if if you're as a man you
understand you're you're competing with
other men for a woman you understand
that
and that's your competition
when you are out of the league
and and if you know that you can't
compete you just have to throw your
hands up I'd say the only way that could
be like like the only way it could work
yeah is if it's a case where if you're
playing away too then I'm involved
I have a question for the guys too I
just thought of this a little off topic
but would you rather have a girl that
has a string of x's that are better than
you or significantly worse than you
and like guys judge a Girl by her axes
and the quality of guy she in keep
rights that's on one hand but on the
other hand if it's too high of a quality
you can't compete so like and and please
don't give me the answer guys be like
there's no guy that can't can't compete
with like okay it's it's Leonardo
DiCaprio it's some whoever your guy hero
is it's him
I I would I would prefer a woman who
it's either him or like like Pookie and
like yeah just give me the Countess give
me the girl just have to Pookie and ray
rays over over the X's that we're taking
oh yeah because now because if I show
you this level you're like she's gonna
be like oh my god I've never experienced
this before wow you know like he bought
my meal oh my gosh my hero yeah exactly
except the guy was like what I was on a
yacht like last year
okay what about you ah yeah
um
I'd have to say I'd rather my girl had
guys that were of high value because I
rate myself as that so
so you driving your girl your your
girl's ex was Michael B Jordan
oh my God yeah because because you know
what the way I see it I say I think that
and he showed her whole life because
then after two years but then I got one
up on him because I've got her do you
know something I'm with him no I hear
that no no I'm with him because
okay okay like I said my man is average
and I've been out with CEOs and every
everyone before
and
let me let me add some more of Amanda
because even though the money you know
why because women that's the man that I
know but let me let me add one thing he
didn't he let me add one thing he does
he they had to have dumped her it wasn't
her choice
that's the whole point no the whole
point
count if she dumped him like is that the
whole point is like that was the ACT she
couldn't keep
so Michael B Jordan showed her the
millionaire lifestyle
bought her a 10 000 roses on balance
and then he's like yeah see you later
love and then you're dealing with that
and she's thinking about my [ __ ] off
that's too much to compete with it's a
curveball but at the same time that [ __ ]
happens in relationships man like I
could have ended for any reason
how do you feel knowing that yoga would
have been dumped by a waste man
the thing is I don't mind that because
no because I don't I I don't I actually
don't mind that yeah I'm not gonna I
don't mind that's just me personally I
don't know who me what you want but I I
don't mind a woman that hasn't
experienced a certain type of lifestyle
and then I introduce her to a lifestyle
I I reckon if I think you'll probably
got a good point still because if she
was dumped by the waste man now you come
not only are you the hero yeah you also
can understand that maybe like yeah he
may have them to be just missed out on
somebody right and then she's a
motivation and she and she feels like oh
my god what have I done to deserve this
man because all of my life I've had men
that wouldn't even buy me a KFC meal do
you realize that Davina just says
something logical Davina you know sorry
that's okay
he's fine Empress I think at this point
Auntie you're doing it purposely
I don't take it personally I know my
name is
like wow that's hilarious what is an
unusual name isn't it it is it is it's
quite unusual personally go on go on
what were you saying
Ronaldo the video Divine the now the
diva
um I was just saying yeah I think that
if obviously given my opinion I probably
would have said that the best girl would
have been the one that was done by the
waste man because she will you'll the
standards that you're bringing are
probably going to be appreciated a lot
more because at the end of the day
people tend to compare what was I then
or am I now you know so you want to
progress not necessarily digress but
then it obviously depends on the details
of the conversation and how why did they
dump what happened that's not your
business already and you're gonna ask
that oh is that no no no well I don't
know and the thing is like the things
you're talking about may not even make
any difference like a guy can fly go out
here fly a day I put her on a boat but
in reality if you're the one that's
actually given her like real time and
value then that might mean more so
imagine a high value guy that treats it
nicely and then dumps her because
actually it's not working out and then
she comes to see sport going to be
living in regret because yeah because
she's gonna be like you know last year I
was in Mauritius right and it was nice
Leonardo DiCaprio's exes stay married
past like 45. because you know Tom Brady
just fell with Giselle with Giselle I
want to see can a woman come back from
Leonardo Dicaprio and stay married it's
crazy because we'll find out I I think I
think we talk about the alpha Widow
right like women get Alpha Widow yeah
like when you're widowed by an alpha
yeah it sounds really weird I actually
hate the word Alpha but I'm so used to
using it okay it's basically like okay
do you do you know a girl that has that
X she always runs back to and can't get
over yeah okay basically that girl sees
that guy as the best she could have done
and some people argue that that's
usually the best sex she's ever had so
like sometimes they'll be like why him
but like that's why and it doesn't
matter who comes next she's always going
to go back to him and the thing is
there's like accounts of women that are
in nursing homes that still think about
a guy from like their teens in their 20s
that's how powerful that's how powerful
it is and and like basically
historically typically if us all were in
like a tribe right and our guy got
killed they would get rid of the women
or take the women and get rid of the
children so we they think that women had
to historically like Get over one guy to
get to the other and they would always
be with the like strongest most Alpha
guy and like historically we wouldn't be
with someone that's like weaker and like
women can't handle that is what they
what they think it is it's true so
that's what I'm saying so you see me I
don't want to be like if a woman's Alpha
Widow don't know I prefer to be the
alpha Widow you see me I like Alpha
widows women I like to play Life on hard
mode so if I if I know if I know uh
personal footballer then she's used to a
certain type of Lifestyle so I know that
I need to level up whatever I'm gonna
work to try and ain't gonna work
because I was out forward and that's the
man I'm with now
and everyone I've been with knows his
name and we discussed it the other day
and I said isn't that a bit weird you
went back to All My Exes
yeah that was the best doctor that's the
best for me 32 years and counting yeah
yeah but before that everybody knows his
name was that because of the sex though
no because he's amazing he's the man
from which all men should be made
that's good look at that look at the
smile that's his face
I wish my woman would be like that 32
years after I met her
because this came up before in
conversation I was we were talking about
Alpha video and I thought about him and
I thought if I could if I found my ex up
and say guess what man that I ended up
with they know his name that's pretty
bad they know his name because I never
hit it and I never had it I was I always
I always said if I said oh you're
another message that was stupid you're
not someone's I can't be in love with
you look at you and looking but I was
quite honest and open about it I could
do no better he was the best ever and a
lot a lot of guys find out that like and
this is just like talking to guys about
their observations of women that the
toxic acts that the women can't like
stop talking about that's the one who
they actually loved because think about
it if you really didn't like a guy
you're not really going to talk about
him you don't even care after you guys
break up but when you're a really into a
guy he really broke your heart that's
the one you complain about that's right
and so like I hate him that's just
another way I loved him he did break my
heart though we just had it's just
something came up and we separated but
yeah you got him now Auntie yeah I
haven't been separated
um about four or five years because I I
found out I got my condition at a name
it was um
oh gosh I saw it on TV yesterday not
insomnia
sex Omnia that's right
that's what I had what happens
insomnia when you suffer from insomnia
and you have sex but the person that
you're with thinks you're awake because
your eyes are open you're going for the
motions and that's why we split because
I thought you had sex with me while I
was sleeping but I got diagna diagnosed
while we split up that I was actually
sleepwalking but I used to drive an
appear in clubs and that and I was
actually having sex with him but he
thought I was awake and unusual you were
asleep
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible